these are 16 characters with the highest
Bounties in the entirety of one piece
and we're gonna list them from three
billion bellies all the way up to over 6
billion starting with the Eustis kid kid
was originally introduced during the
celebrity art with a bounty of 315
million bellies although this bounty was
the highest among supernovas it doesn't
necessarily mean he was the strongest
kid mostly earned his Bounty by harming
many civilians and not necessarily for
his strain sometime after the summit War
his Bounty was raised from 315 million
to 470 million bellies for his
achievements in the new world kid ate
the magnet magnet fruit a devil fruit
that allows him to attract and control
metal objects with magnetism this fruit
proved to be a great fit for him as he
was able to use the metal to form a
prosthetic arm when he lost his real one
in the battle against the red hair
Pirates kid's goal was to track down and
defeat Emperors in order to take their
place he eventually played a crucial
part in defeating the emperor big mom
which earned him a monstrous Bounty of
three billion bellies however he
couldn't take her place as the vacant
Emperor places were taken by Luffy and
buggy kid was only one out of 16
characters on this list and let's
continue with his rival from the worst
generation truffleguard the law lost a
pirate from North Blue and the captain
of the heart Pirates he possesses the
power of the elope no me allowing him to
create a spherical territory where he
can reform and control matter contrary
to kid we previously mentioned law
doesn't seek to cause destruction and
Achieve Emperor's status he instead
wants to find one piece and also learn
the meaning and purpose of the will of D
same as kid law was also introduced
during the celebrity art with a bounty
of 200 million bellies after that during
the time skip his Benny was eventually
raised to 440 million and then Frozen
due to him aligning with the government
in joining the seven Warlords however
after helping Straw Hat Pirates during
the dresserosa arc his title was revoked
and his Bounty was reinstated and even
raised a little bit to 500 million
bellies eventually his belly would be
raised to 3 billion values for his role
in taking down big mom during the wano
country Arc number 14 Monkey D louvi
Luffy desires to find the legendary
treasure left behind by Goldie Roger and
become the pirate king which he believes
is the person with the most freedom in
the world Luffy also desires that you
press that subscribe button down below
and since he is the main character that
always gets what he wants you kind of
have to do it thanks Luffy is the
character that just keeps getting
stronger and stronger as time goes on
and this fact is reflected in his Bounty
he gained his first Bounty of 30 million
bellies for defeating the strongest
pirate captains of the East blue which
then increased to a hundred million
after defeating crocodile in alabasta
after his crew invaded any sloppy his
Bounty further increased to 300 million
his sizable Bounty cause Luffy to be
included among the 11 supernovas and
even among them he had the second
highest Bounty two years after the war
with a bounty of 400 million bellies he
entered the new world and began
challenging the Emperors directly with
his Bounty eventually increasing to 3
billion bellies after defeating
doflamingo sweet commanders and the
strongest creature in the world kaido
although Luffy has achieved some
impossible Feats the same can't be said
said for the next character who got his
Bounty completely by accident lucky the
clown is a very Vain and egotistical
character who seeks to be glorified and
feared by others due to his past and
some misunderstandings the world
government saw him as an incredibly
strong pirate although he's not and he
invited him to join the seven Warlords
at that point buggy had a low Bounty of
only 15 million bellies but after the
abolition of the warlord system and his
alliance with mihawk and crocodile his
Bounty was reinstated and raised to 3
billion 189 million bellies number 12
drakul mihawk jakul mihawk is a world
famous pirate who holds the title
strongest swordsman in the world he was
strong enough to rival Shanks as they
competed fiercely in legendary duels
until Shanks lost his left arm mihawk
swordsmanship is extremely versatile he
can create immensely powerful compressed
air slashes that can destroy enormous
icebergs using the strong blade
swordsmanship and deflect the course of
bullets with masterful Precision using
the gentle blade he can also cut through
steel with extremes and precision as
demonstrated with the scale-bodied Mr
one in the latest chapters of the manga
we finally got to see mihawk's new
Bounty and as we all expected it was
enormous by forming an alliance with
crocodile and buggy he earned himself a
bounty of 3 billion 590 million bellies
it's crazy to think that there are still
11 characters with higher bounties than
mihawk number 11. kuzan so what's
koozon's Bounty well although that fact
wasn't revealed yet in the story since
he wasn't Admiral he is Bounty must be
really high we also can't forget that
since kuzan worked for the government he
probably knows many of their secrets
which they would kill to protect if
that's not enough to persuade you that
he deserves this spot on the list just
remember that he also joined one of the
pirate Crews the world government fears
the most and even the five Elders called
him an enormous power the greatest
Testament to aokiji's strength is his
duel against Akainu in which he matched
the future Fleet Admiral for 10 days
until he suffered his defeat but
speaking a tremendous deal of raw power
and endurance based on all this I'd say
that kuzan's bani will be around 3.6
billion bellies number 10. Rayleigh even
in his old age he was still powerful
enough to contend with kizado and
prevent him from attacking Luffy in the
crew however during the fight he quickly
got tired implying that he's nowhere
near the level of endurance and stamina
he had in his younger days this implies
that when he was in his prime he was
most likely stronger than in current
Admiral and possibly an emperor level
fighter during their fight Rayleigh told
kizario a few people would withdraw my
bounty I'd be able to retire in peace
this means that even after 22 years his
Bounty is still active as Roger is the
only one in his career to have his
Bounty revealed we'll have to speculate
a bit to guess what rayleigh's Bounty
most likely is in his prime it's quite
possible that Rayleigh was the strongest
swordsman in the world since besides
Odin no one else could stand their
ground against Rayleigh in a sword fight
he also reached laughtail and it was
revealed during salvadi Arc that he
knows all the world's secrets in the
events of the Void Century in my opinion
his Bounty must be higher than kouzons
and I would guess it's probably a around
3.7 billion bellies number nine Odin
even though he was a pirate for a very
short time Oda was considered one of the
strongest pirates in the world his
strength left a great impression on
everyone around him especially kaido who
even 20 years after Odin's death regards
him is one of the few people in the
whole world capable of fighting him due
to his adventures with the Whitebeard
and Roger Pirates he was stated to have
grown much stronger than before
returning to wano Invincible although
Odin's Bounty was never revealed he was
undoubtedly one of the biggest threats
to the world government just think about
it Odin was a part of two notorious
Crews the Whitebeard and Roger Pirates
he was also able to read and write in
poneoglyph language and on top of all
that he also reached laughtail and
learned everything there is to know
about the world and government secrets
the world government surely tried to
catch Odin with everything they had and
therefore I'd guess that they gave him
the Bounty of at least 3.8 billion
bellies number eight Shiki although
Shiki isn't a character many people
consider when talking about bounties
it's important to mention that he was
one of the most powerful Pirates of his
generation right alongside Legends like
Roger and Whitebeard one of shiki's
biggest achievements is battling against
GARP and sangoku in the prime of their
power their battle destroyed half of the
city until he eventually lost however
even after that he did The Impossible
and managed to escape the impenetrable
prison impaled down which no one had
managed to do before despite the
government's big desire to catch him
again Shiki remained hidden for over 20
years with seemingly no information on
what he's doing or where he is even
though we have very little information
to go by at this moment the fact that
she be rival the likes of Roger is
enough to put him among the Emperors on
this list I'll guess that his Bounty was
most likely around 4 billion bellies
although we have no clue what shiki's
intentions are there is one character
who's even more mysterious than him and
that's red hair Shanks Shanks earned
himself the title of Emperor and is
considered a great Threat by the world
government he's one of the few people in
the world who can use all three types of
hockey with conquerors Hockey being his
most powerful variation this was seen
during the one work when he released a
massive burst of hockey from his ship
miles outside of wanowan managed to stop
Admiral greenbull without even entering
the country due to this feat we can
assume that Shanks most likely has the
absolute strongest hockey in the entire
series as no other character could come
even close to subduing the Admiral in
this fashion shank's current Donnie was
revealed to be 4 billion 48 million 900
000 bellies although this is an
impressive Bounty due to Shanks being a
pacifist and not really battling anyone
most of the time I feel like this bounty
is much more lower than it could have
been it'd be really great to see what
his Bounty would be if he ever started
wreaking chaos like kaido or Blackbeard
I'm sure it would Skyrocket number six
big mom Charlotte lean lean was one of
the four Emperors and rulers of total
land she was first issued a bounty of 50
million bellies at the age of six which
makes her the youngest known individual
to ever have a bounty placed on their
head even younger than Robin who
received her Bounty at the age of eight
she was also the youngest person ever to
become a captain of a pirate crew having
led the big bomb pirate since she was
six years old lelin quickly became
notorious for conquering islands and
killing their citizens which immediately
boosted her Bounty 10 times to 500
million bellies sometime after that she
joined Rox Pirates the most feared
pirate crew in history with members like
kaido Whitebeard and Shiki due to her
actions over the following years she
eventually earned herself a bounty of 4
billion 388 million and became one of
the most feared people on the Seas
although she was an emperor I still feel
this bounty was a bit high and probably
issued due to her influence and actions
rather than raw fighting prowess number
5. Dragon although zigzag abilities have
not been revealed yet dragon is
certainly a very powerful fighter he's
been seen several times seemingly
controlling wind which many fans
speculate is his devil fruit power
combined with a strong hockey this type
of power would make dragon one of the
strongest characters in the series now I
know many of the fans are disappointed
that I didn't put dragon in the first
place but it just doesn't make sense to
me don't get me wrong I believe dragon
has an immense Bounty but considering
the bounties of other revolutionary Army
members I really don't think his Bounty
will be higher than Rogers for now his
Bounty should be around 4.4 billion
bellies number four kaido as the Beast
Pirates Governor kaido has authority
over a massive 20 000 strong pirate
organization and due to his alliance
with Shogun arochi he enjoys authority
over thousands of wano country's Samurai
forces kaido grew up in the Vodka
Kingdom and was a part of its Army which
invaded and looted nearby cities by the
age of 10 kaido was already the
Kingdom's strongest Soldier a few years
later he was sold to the Marines but he
easily managed to escape the warship
which ultimately earned him his first
value of 7 million bellies after that he
allowed himself to be captured numerous
times to eat the food on the battleships
escaping with ease once he'd had his
fill the most remarkable thing about
kaido is his body which is pretty much
non-destructible not even with regular
Armament hockey this was showcased
multiple times when Luffy attacked kaido
was seemingly no effect and when he
jumped from sky island and fell ten
thousand in meters without any injuries
whatsoever through his actions kaido
earned himself a bounty of 4 billion 600
million one hundred thousand bellies
which makes him the person with the
highest known Bounty Post Time skip
although kaido's Bounty is impressive
we've still got three characters left to
cover with even higher bounties than him
starting with his former crewmate
Whitebeard in his prime Whitebeard was a
rival to Roger and following Roger's
death was widely recognized as the
strongest man in the world with the
highest active Bounty at some point in
his life Whitebeard ain't the
guruguranomi the devil fruit considered
the strongest in the paramecia class and
according to some had the power to
destroy the world although it's unknown
how much the first Bounty Whitebeard
ever got was it was probably pretty big
considering he was a member of rocks
pirates in his youth during his life he
was the only pirate able to match Roger
in one-on-one battle with the two
fighting many times with no clear winner
even though he got old and extremely
sick Whitebeard was still a number one
threat to the world government and the
pirate they feared the most during the
summit War Marine Ford Whitebeard
showcased his might multiple times by
beating a kainu and contending evenly
with other Admirals despite suffering a
deadly wound just minutes earlier
whitebeard's influence and might earned
him an exceptional Bounty of 5 billion
46 million bellies Which is higher than
all current and former known Emperors
before we cover the character with the
highest bounty on the list let's first
quickly cover gulty Roger Goldie Roger
was the first and only person currently
in the show to reach the final island in
the new world to become king of pirates
he and his crew are sad to have
conquered the ground line and were
considered nearly Unstoppable Roger is
one of the First characters introduced
in the show and the first known owner of
the legendary straw hat which was later
passed down to Shanks and Luffy he was
one of the few people that could use all
three forms of hockey and also had the
power called voice of all things which
allowed him to hear objects and animals
that don't speak human language as the
pirate king and the person who knew all
the world's Secrets Roger was eventually
granted a bounty of 5 billion 564
million eight hundred thousand bellies
the highest known bounty in the history
of piracy now before I reveal who the
character with the highest Bounty is I
just want to give an honorable mention
to joyboy due to the lack of information
about him and the void Century it's
unclear if he had a bounty at all but if
he did he'd definitely be on the top of
our list above all other characters
number one rock Steve zebik Roxy's was
the pirate King's greatest enemy and one
of the most fearsome pirates in history
he was so fearsome in fact that after
his defeat the world government
completely erased his name from history
with the majority of the world not even
knowing that he ever existed the extent
of zedek's powers is unknown and whether
he possessed devil fruit powers or
solely relied on hockey remains to be
seen now many of you are probably
wondering why I put rocks higher on the
list than Roger well the fact that the
government agreed to work with Roger in
order to exterminate rocks in my opinion
gives us all the information we need to
determine who they considered the bigger
threat at that time also despite knowing
all the secrets Rogers seemingly never
spoke publicly about them nor did he try
to destroy the world government while on
the other hand Rox wanted to become king
of the world and uncover all the secrets
to gov government was hiding this is
purely speculation but I believe Rock's
Bounty was most likely around 6 billion
bellies did you ever wonder if all straw
hats together could defeat Luffy click
on this video to find out the answer may
surprise you